okay man some of you guys are so
impatient something guys need to learn
some patience man my goodness
freaking out losing your minds oh my
goodness what's going on guys how's
everybody doing like I was setting up
the I was setting up the speech
recognition for my for my computer like
I guess it's been three minutes and
people are like are you okay
like are you are you dying like this are
you dead brav like are you okay are you
okay
is everything okay I'm like it's been
three minutes guys if I said I was gonna
start at 9:30 and I didn't start until
like 10 o'clock then I could see where
people would be freaked out but it's
been like three minutes
yeah it'll be fine I do love pie like I
definitely love pie
forever you said yesterday just do the
Shia LaBeouf I Love You Man you're my
main man you're my main man so do you
ever feel I feel all the time like I
have feels is this the Shia LaBeouf it's
everyday is Shia LaBeouf appreciation
day like every day is Appreciation Day
what's your favorite come with us yeah
what's your favorite Secret Wars tie-in
um definitely old man Logan old man
Logan solid like I was initially kind of
like excited for like he was a Future
Passed I was like hey this is starting
off cool and then just just dropped off
kind of garbagey and so I was like okay
that sucks so I stopped worrying about
it but I'm not that big of a fan of it
um this is your first time here well
welcome welcome
like welcome I'm glad you're here like
this is cool um
The Voice is here I don't know if any of
you guys know but I did a I did an
audiobook recording of go the F to sleep
on Rob reads because people were like
you should you should do that and I was
like I mean why not it's just a channel
where I just read stuff why not it'd
just be fun so I did that and I uploaded
it and it seems to be pretty popular
well relatively popular so far so people
seem to dig it and yeah it's it was it
was funny it was funny why are you so
successful in charismatic at me I don't
know I mean I guess I am I mean I just
talk about stuff that I love like I love
making videos and stuff and talking
about how did you like school and
college wasn't really for me College was
okay
it was I took a couple semesters and
took I get stuff like that and it just
wasn't really my cup of tea that you
know that means so that's me like don't
skip that on college go like go to
college and get a degree how do you
think the DC heroes would handle would
have handled the incursions time runs
out mmm that's a tough that's the tough
question I think they probably would
have panicked and died like I have no
idea I don't know I mean they had crisis
on Infinite Earths so I guess I probably
handled it the same way so Rob where did
deadpool get his teleporter from from
cable I think that's what you're talking
about like yeah he got it from cable oh
I'm all out of coffee I had coffee but
then I drew and drank it all I was
setting up the voice the voice
recognition for my PC which is one of
the reasons that was a couple minutes
late but um I mean I think I'm gonna
start like dictating my scripts using
voice recognition and kind of seeing how
that goes like well we'll see what's up
cuz it's easier for me to just like say
what I want what I know it's easy for
you to just kind of speak my thoughts
out loud then it is for me to type it
out not oh no why it's just like there's
a barrier there where it's just like I
can't do it for some reason started
watching DBZ your and oh you're in it
you've never seen Dragon Ball Z before
like DBZ is amazing
like I love DBZ yeah I answered why are
you okay this is a Q&A session why do
you guys get some amazed when I answer
your questions like what kind of Q&A
would this be if I if I didn't answer
questions if I just made up my own
questions and answer them
robbery's yes Rober eats someone get
coffee stat get coffee get us coffee now
why is this entry dead because he just
wasn't doing well and fans hated him
fans hated his character like butts
entry was I thought he was really good
with his limited series under Jenkins
and Jay Lee and then they then like
casada was like let's take all that
Marvel Knights stuff and just fold it
over into the main universe and then it
just got dumb after that so people hated
it dammit Robby Siri it's Lifeson you
can't don't take life too seriously guys
you'll never make it out a lot respondet
this one video was fun to make like I
enjoyed it
I mean at this point I want to
experiment with Indy books like you know
spawn the organs of spawn and the story
of how I became spawn you know that was
fun and I want to experience with other
stuff like I want to do oh I want to
show you guys this first I want to show
you guys this first check this out so I
got a one in 100 variant cover for Star
Wars and what this means is that in
order for the comic book store to get it
they have to order 100 issues of Secret
Wars like sycamores number 7 in order to
get this variant and yeah like this or
I'm sorry not so not so good where's
Star Wars they have to order one they
had to order 100 copies of Star Wars in
order to get this variant cover and so
they have I don't know how many they
sold but yeah this is the variant cover
for issue number 7 and it looks
amazingly it looks nice I like it like I
think I'm gonna I'm gonna get this
autographed by probably like Stan Lee
hopefully at some point and then I don't
know if George Lucas is gonna be at like
conventions or anything but it'd be cool
to get like a Stan Lee and George Lucas
autograph and then get this thing box
stuff you know get it graded and get it
boxed and just like leave it that way
like never ever take it out or anything
so um let's see who's your favorite
Marvel character um probably the century
and in terms of his original I guess
maybe this original story is what I love
the most like in terms of characters
probably Wolverine like the old man
Logan version of Wolverine um mmm
Super Saiyan 4 versus Super Saiyan God
Super Saiyan well see here's a kicker
guys for those of you guys who were who
were reading who were following up on
the Dragon Ball universe at the moment I
don't here's my question how many of you
here saw Dragon Ball GT that's that's
the question I'll ask before you guys
before I before I go any further
Rob explained Sandman overture please my
life wouldn't be complete what do I
think about we are Robin it's decent
enough I like the idea we are Robin the
problem is is it's the problem is this
like you know are those tie-ins gonna
matter you know I'm not really x like
all those stories going to really
continue on are they gonna become
anything stellar I'd like a group of
teenagers fighting you know we are Robin
I like I like that idea story focused on
teenagers
that's a cool concept and having said
that you know I got to be honest I like
the idea of a single Robin fighting
beside Batman
it's just something I've always been a
huge fan of you know I've always been
been a huge a huge idea I've always been
I've always enjoyed it
there we go yeah I can't talk okay
absolutely sometimes like absolutely not
okay so for those of you guys who saw
who never saw a Dragon Ball GT Dragon
Ball GT was like a lot of fans hated
like a lot of me I don't like Dragon
Ball GT like I think it was it was an
awful TV show and I didn't really dig it
too much but you know that being said
there are people who do enjoy Johnny
ball GT was the follow-up to Dragon Ball
Z and it was basically trying to
capitalize on the popularity of Dragon
Ball Z the problem was that a curatorial
I didn't come back for Dragon Ball GT
like he wasn't the one running this show
and so in Dragon Ball GT really one of
the only things that people care about
that came out of that show was Super
Saiyan 4 and the way the Super Saiyan 4
worked and I was originally gonna
include this in the Dragon Ball or in
the Super Saiyan transformations but I
wanted to leave it out because I didn't
really want to focus that like I want to
focus on Dragon Ball Z and what's
considered canon as part of the Dragon
Ball Z universe the movies and I guess
the movies are kind of canon if you want
them to be but you know I figured I'd
focus on the Dragon Ball Z universe
going into Dragon Ball super because
super seems to wreak on Dragon Ball GT
but nonetheless the way it worked in
Dragon Ball GT was that if a Saiyan had
a tail and they looked at something that
emitted brute race and all brute rates
were was basically like I was always
talking to geekdom 101 about this
because I didn't really understood brute
ways when I was younger like I never
really understood how that worked
brute waves are basically just like
light reflecting from the Sun or I guess
from light from the Sun reflecting off
the planet Earth and that creates brute
race and so in the story there was there
was a it was whole different thing with
baby you know I kind of said but unless
what is up happening is I Goku that gets
his tail back he looks at the Sun around
so he looks at the earth when the sun's
light so light is reflecting off of it
in the form of brute rays he turns into
a golden ape a golden great ape when a
Saiyan masters their ability to control
themselves as a golden great ape then
they turn into a Super Saiyan 4 and
Super Saiyan 4 was super powerful it was
a God level powerful that's basically
what they were saying they were like he
was he was on the level of a god
and it was it was interesting to see but
fans were just like this sucks
like blunts waves blunts waves smoking
blunts waves but fans were like this
like this is this show sucks and so like
what seems to be happening is super
saying you know Super Saiyan God Super
Saiyan seems to be like red counting it
which is fine by me I don't care like I
didn't like Dragon Ball GT that much but
you know that's that's why I really left
it out is because right now it's not
Canon like at least it doesn't seem to
be they really haven't said anything to
indicate that you know that it matters
at all the lag is real a girl on your
end I would say um but yeah so
everywhere consider doing the entire
squad series explain I mean this one I'm
just kind of swinging for the fences I'm
just trying different things out I may
get into that at some point along the
line but I'm Bob wouldn't I wouldn't say
yes right now
um hull Kirby's shoes better hope I mean
that's not a debate but Vegeta met yeah
but you could kind of mastered it hi Rob
do you write or illustrate any comics of
your own and no I don't have any I don't
know you know I'm it's somebody asked me
that once before in a livestream and and
I made an analogy of like being a DJ you
know because I've got I've got new mark
NS in the closet back there and I used
to DJ like way back when you know it was
it was fun you know DJing and that kind
of thing
it's like DJing and producing do I want
to produce content or do I like I do
what do I want to produce material or do
I want to like just enjoy the material
read the material and so on I'd rather
read it I don't want to be a producer I
don't want to make you know comic books
and write comic books anything like that
you know because I'd rather I rather
just read them you know see what kind of
other things people can make because
there's people out there that are far
better and far more creative than I am
so you know I wouldn't really be
interested in jumping into that um works
video game movie ever Street Fighter
you've been doing great new great on the
new stuff on your channel well this is
delving in a commis because here's the
thing guys like my my channel was
founded on comic books like Marvel DC
content and those aren't going anywhere
you know right now we're we're getting
ready to jump into Batman with 9 to the
owl's and then death of the family and
then in game 2 get current on Batman so
hopefully by like the 6th of September
like Batman in game will be finished I'm
working on the script right now for a
night of the elves but
you know like there's the Jean Grey
thing that we're doing right now and all
that kind of good stuff and once we're
done with that you know me right now the
Jean great thing it's just something I
felt like doing because there's Secret
Wars and nothing else in Marvel right
now well none of the tie-ins are
completed like the tie-ins aren't done
they're just still going on it so this
really just kind of there's really
nothing going on a mall right now it's
just kind of a dead period and it sucks
you know and so so I'm just you know
doing Marvel stories that I find
interesting you know and I love the
story of the Phoenix saga and the Dark
Phoenix saga and that kind of stuff and
so you know I figured I'd do different
things about that but I also want to
expand out you know I don't want to be
just the Marvel and DC guy so I figured
you know I took a risk like I was like
you know what I'm just gonna do a Dragon
Ball video and see what happened that
people were like I love Dragon Ball Z
Wow okay I'm down with that and so let's
do some Dragon Ball Z videos and so you
know I want to do a Dragon Ball video a
week and plus someone to branch out into
indie comics you know if any of you guys
caught the a weekly pull podcast which I
uploaded onto YouTube the other day I
was talking to to Tiffany and to Faust
and I was like teach me about indie
comics tell me the best ones that you
can think of and a lot of people were
saying a lot of different things some
were saying east of West which I got
east of West some people were saying you
know like like invincible some people
were saying which is people were saying
different things so I was like okay if
I'm gonna jump in indie comics I'm gonna
start with spawn the the original super
successful independent comic book
franchise The Walking Dead probably is
more successful now but you know I'd say
that in terms of like indie comics sold
and so on I think that a spawn probably
beat it out for quite a good amount of
time I mean the first issue sold
one-and-a-half million copies so but
yeah so yeah heroes heroes reborn I mean
it's it's all that comic book lawyer you
know all that superhero kind of stuff
you know that that I like talking about
and and yeah so that's that's pretty
much you know where things are going is
to is to you know maintain what it was
it made my channel successful but also
try new things you know and they're
gonna people who are gonna be adverse to
it you know some are gonna say like like
I don't wanted you to try new things I
want you to stick with old things but
you know as times change you know and
the only way to stay successful and not
becoming irrelevant on YouTube is to
evolve and constantly grow and
constantly change and so the way I the
way I take it is that people who say you
know we don't want your channel to
change or basically telling me like we
don't want your channel to stay
successful we
want your channel to fail and and so
those people usually just get ignored
but Young Justice renewal rumor fact I
have no idea but I like the idea of a
Young Justice like I would why would
love to see continued um huh oh your
opinion on Rominger and letter a joke ok
we'll talk about that here in a second
like I like the idea of Young Justice
because to me there always needs to be
an element like Justice League is cool
people love the idea of like the
grown-up adult superheroes fighting and
stuff like that but there always needs
to be an element of comic books that are
simply just designed for young kids for
for young adult readers
yeah I've seen fear The Walking Dead
it's amazing um there need to be books
that are designed for for young adult
readers but that are also you know that
also have adult themes you know because
kids who you know people who are are 13
14 15 years old don't want to read a
comic book that treats them like they're
you know like there are seven years old
you know I mean when a person sits down
and says I'm gonna read young Young
Justice they don't want to read the book
and feel as though they're being catered
or the books catering to seven year old
kids they want to be like you know I'm
not necessarily an adult but I'm not an
idiot and don't treat me like an idiot
and Young Justice doesn't do that Young
Justice treats young adults like young
adult young adults and storm is a mega
level um she is that powerful she's
possibly omega-level my hair is on point
I know you're not blocked um but that's
that's why people love you know Teen
Titans us why they love Young Justice
because it's a combination of books a
cater to you know young adults that
doesn't you know treat them like idiots
and having said that what was the was
the question before somebody asked a
question before I said we were gonna
talk about that they said
Oh would you rather have a really
well-written event that's really long or
an event that's mediocre mediocre too
bad but short all the answers that
questions I'd rather have a long event
and then here's here's the end here's
why here's why how many of you guys are
familiar with Jonathan Hickman raise
your hands raiser
I'm gonna assume most of you if not all
of you are familiar with Jonathan
Hickman those of you who aren't you are
missing out Jonathan Hickman is and you
guys should go follow him on Twitter
just be like how much deserved comments
explain sent me here how much explained
said I need to follow you once but but
Jonathan Hickman is solid like he is
very very good okay yeah Jared Leto
that's right yeah we'll talk about that
here in a second the Jonathan Hickman is
great when he tells a story because
here's what Jonathan Hickman does
Jonathan Hickman says like there's this
theme going on here and there's this
thing going on here and there's this
thing here and this thing down here and
down here and all over the place you
know and then as the story comes to an
end it's all it comes into a singular
point then she was it all merges
together into a singular thing and it's
amazing the way it's done because I saw
an interview once where he said that he
starts at the end of a story he knows
what he wants he knows what the he wants
the end to be and then works his way
forward that's the best way to write a
story because you know by the time it
ends people don't feel like he were just
kind of desperate to end it in your
desire and then that happens and the
story's overdone all right let's move
one of the next thing fans don't get
that feeling you know like they get the
feeling of okay you know this story is a
complete story it's a full-on you know
total telling and that's why people love
Hickman because he does that he writes
these great big huge long drawn-out
stories go on for years sometimes and
and they're amazing you know having said
that long events were a pain in the ass
for me because I explained it all but
but nonetheless you know I love reading
the great big huge alone events okay
Jared Leto yogurt okay so as I
understand it the the on running theory
is that Jared Leto is either tort-like
either is was robbing like was Jason
Todd or torture Jason Todd but is not
the only winning theory that like but
like Jared Leto is Jason Todd like the
Joker is Jason Todd in this in the story
if it is like that theory
is amazing he like well why are people
asking if their blocks like you're not
blocked I know you're not blocked
because I can see you otherwise it would
just say you're blocked um let's see uh
yeah like somebody confirmed for me if
that's that's the rumor or not that like
Jared Leto that like you know Jason Todd
is the Joker and that Joker 2.0 I'm
Batman Beyond yeah I figured it was
debunked like I figured it wasn't true
but you know that would have been a
really really cool idea we just started
a little bit ago we just start about 20
minutes ago so when I read Hawkeye kills
the Marvel Universe absolutely not
how's Hawkeye gonna kill the Marvel
Universe Hawkeye got killed in the
Marvel Universe no I couldn't I couldn't
see that um do you like the idea of
Captain a Captain America Civil War
though I love the idea I think it's
gonna be awesome
um I like the idea that well it's kind
of mash up like it's clear and with the
direction things are going that the
movie is gonna be like a slim down
stripped-down version of the comic book
series and then you know I'm like I'd
mention on periscope yesterday for those
of you guys that don't you know follow
me on periscope
check me out they're like I'd get on
periscope all the time but you know it
they really couldn't do like their
full-on Civil War ving in a single movie
that would be outrageous like you'd have
way too much going on it would it would
put like age of Ultron to shame in terms
of how much stuff you have going and how
much stuff they would have going on you
know having said that I like the idea
that it's pretty much condensed down and
is basically the main stars of the
Avengers film Avengers age of Ultron and
a couple of the characters black panther
I like what they have going on so far
I'd like to see it expanded like I'd
like to see this say like this is the
initial confrontation and over the
course of like phase four it's just
gonna be an expansion of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Civil War they may or
may not it's fine it's not a huge deal
to me
but I'd like to see that happen having
said that with what they have so far I'm
down with it like I'm not upset at all I
think it's cool let's see can Captain
America kill the Marvel Universe yeah he
probably could have you tried
the Winter Soldier vs. Red Hood a Red
Hood gets that one like I love the
Winter Soldier Bucky Barnes is cool man
but I got to give it to the Red Hood see
here's a problem that with debates like
that like whenever you say like Marvel
character vs. DC character it doesn't
matter like it doesn't matter whether
they're better or not it's just fans of
that character are gonna be like my
character would win not because I really
think he would but because I'm a fan of
that character I don't want to see him
and that's fine to see him in nature I
mean why would you be a fan of a
character and then like say that he
loses every fight sitting eating every
fight that he gets in but there's no
winning like I thought about doing a
video on Goku vs. Vegeta like who's
better Goku vs. Vegeta but that video
would it would be nuts
you know because Vegeta fans will be
like Vegeta it's clearly better and Goku
fans would be like Oh who's clearly
better and they would be all upset and
you know and I'll hurt have their
feelings all hurt and everything you
know if I were just like they're their
characters not as good as the other one
you know if Goku fans about if I told
Goku fans AGID is better like ohoo fans
will be all upset if I told Vegeta fans
they go kid was better you know video
fans would be all upset and so I may
just jump into it anyway and see what's
up but I don't want to turn my channel
into a place where people just like dump
all their anger and rage in the world
you know and so I might stay away from a
topic like that but would love a review
on shield who doesn't intend if you read
this series I think it would be in your
wheelhouse it's ok shields not shields
all arrived I don't think it was all
that great thoughts on Panos I mean he's
real I mean he's there you know like
he's in love with mr. death and he loves
killing people it's like it's like me
Superman and my friends mad yeah exactly
it's exactly what it's like what Captain
America died and Civil War probably most
likely I see him dying um
either that or dying in an infinity war
as far as I know he's signed on for
Captain America 3 Civil War and then one
more movie I could be wrong but I'm
pretty sure that's correct we have two
hurricanes heading towards Hawaii this
week well that's stay safe don't get
hurt I mean hurricanes a dangerous man
like introducing magic to the MCU
thoughts it is long overdue we
definitely need some magic in the MCU
and here's why the MCU is really really
cool because you got characters of
powers but all the powers are like
science-based you know like
Captain America's is based on a serum
devised by scientists Tony Stark's
powers he's a scientist and Iike greats
who creates super genius stuff with the
Mandarin we thought there was going to
be some level of magic but there wasn't
it was literally just you know a
substance you know extremists something
that interacts with the human DNA and
the Mandarin himself you know was was
proven you know Trevor whatever his name
is was proven to be an actor you know so
now the Mandarin now just just to be
sure guys the Mandarin does exist in in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as far as
we know we just haven't seen him yet and
we may not you know but um you know all
the all the elements there are
science-based the Incredible Hulk
because science based you know it's
interaction with DNA and so on you know
the only thing that really kind of
stretches away from science is like as
guard and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is basically says well they're gods and
they've been around for you know
millennia and countless years and so
yeah and so like we need someone who
comes along and it's just like what I'm
doing here is quite literally equivalent
to pulling a rabbit out of a hat
like I'm just it's magic you know and we
need that like we need something worse
just it's just magic because it
introduces all kinds of different
elements it introduces new alternate
realities and all different kinds of
things dimensions and stuff Trevor
Slattery there we go it introduces a
different dimensions and things like
that you know and it's a cool concept
you know it's a really cool idea you
know and I think we're overdue for that
because I like the realism of the MCU
but anything done in excess is terrible
regardless of how much you love it and
despite the fact that the MCU takes a
realistic you know approach to comic
books I love that element I also want to
see some fantasy thrown in there I want
to see some some you know well there's
no way that could there's that's
ridiculous like I'm gonna see some of
that you know thrown in there and I
think that Doctor Strange would be that
like he'd be able to do those things
what do I think about she McGrath yeah
he's a he's one of the many many angled
ones I mean he's not he was a big
villain he killed the the ancient one
aside from that you know do you like
halo um halos all right I used to play
it all the time back in 2007 Rob oh my
god his image will be forklift what are
you talking about what now his image
will be forklifted to every hype
your opinion on what caused us of a war
the comics was about registration yeah
as far as I know it's gonna be about
registration and I think it was like
some leak that happened a while ago
where they were talking about um Oh God
oh they were talking about like the the
casting the they were casting extras and
the plot the synopsis as it was given to
the extras was that the the movie's
gonna be on registration and it makes
sense you know I think that what they're
gonna do I don't I mean we won't really
know the details of the plot until
information is actually released or
until the trailer comes out or something
like that to give us an idea
right now it's all just kind of
speculation out there and you know leaks
and you know we can't verify those leaks
so I guess to make it you know make it
what you will but as far as I know with
the idea of a civil war it's gonna focus
on the it's gonna focus on the phone off
um age of Ultron you know that you had
some robot that swore up a city and you
know try to destroy the earth and you
had the fight between the Hulk and Iron
Man all that kind of good stuff and so
the government's like it's time for
registration like we need to register
heroes or something do something to keep
them under control and that makes sense
you know yeah civil wars not being held
accountable basically Dark Souls is so
amazing Rob yeah I never got into Dark
Souls like I've I've heard it's a real
tough game though by a black panther vs
Man do you reek in with Thrones no but I
watch the TV show and it's pretty
amazing
although right now I think it's on
hiatus until he comes back yeah the
teams have been confirmed yeah I know
about that we were talking about that on
periscope last night Scarlet Witch is
the problem what do you think will
happen to the Fantastic Four I think
eventually I don't know
I think Fox is not gonna let that go
foxes I think Fox is like hey look guys
we just made that video so we can keep
the right saying we don't care how many
foxes I'm gonna be honest with you guys
Fox is a multi-billion dollar company
they don't care about public opinion on
the Fantastic Four if the movie makes
money they're gonna keep on making them
if the movies don't make money they're
not gonna make them here's gonna be the
key the key is going to be if they're
reboot like if the the sequel succeeds
if it doesn't succeed in the probably
give the rights back now having said
that if you guys want Marvel to get the
rights back to the Fantastic Four stop
going to see the fantastic four movies
I'm not gonna go see him anymore like
you know and that's the best way to give
the rights back to Marvel yes don't go
see the Fantastic Four movie that's the
best thing I can do to advocate that you
know is don't go see the movies you know
let the movies fail financially and when
they fail and Fox isn't making any money
on it don't give the rights back so um
let's see since you like sensory so much
do you have the Marvel Legends century
figure no I don't they'd be cool if I
did though
have you played until dawn no but I was
watching chris smoove playthrough
those are the guys who don't know chris
smoove is this really a really funny guy
he does he used to call duty videos back
in the day but he's over he's a really
funny video game youtuber he's like 2
million subscribers are the guys
channels huge I mean I've been watching
him for you know years since about 2009
or so like I've been watching him for a
long time but he's doing a playthrough
of until until dawn and it's really
funny so I had to go check that out if I
were you guys do you prefer physical
copies of comics or are you digital I
prefer physical it will it depends you
know I'm awful unlimited for when I'm
going through stories and stuff like
that and really really old comics and
things like that like I prefer obviously
digital because I can't afford to go out
and buy a copy of amazing fantasy number
you know or and I'm starting out amazing
with fantasy of yeah mazing fantasy
number 15 I can't afford to go out and
buy one of those because those things in
the worst condition cost fifty thousand
dollars in the best condition they're
worth hundreds of thousands of dollars
and so you know for newer stuff you know
buying new things secret worse things
like that I prefer physical copies let's
see I don't have any water that's such
is the Xbox one worth buying man not
really I mean I bought it just so I
could play Minecraft with my niece and I
still haven't done it yet I need to hook
it up so I can hang out so we can hang
out and talk in someone but that's amin
i don't know i mean i disconnected it at
all you know like i just connect to the
ps4 the xbox one things like that you
know
so do you think WatchMojo it's getting
overrated now WatchMojo makes great
videos Sean the shot clock cheese crisps
food was amazing um let's see
how much to explain stop with vs. and
let's ask smart questions I was under
the impression that I was doing a QA am
I wrong
like I'm not I was I was under that
impression that I was doing the Q&A I'm
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm not the one
doing the Q&A I don't know um
who's your favorite superhero uh we've
got over that before my favorite
superhero is the century
have you played Batman Arkham Knight yes
I played back in Batman Arkham Knight
the only Batman the best Arkham Knight
game the best Batman game that I've
played so far is oh my god the one that
just came out now you know you guys know
what I'm talking about
um what time is it over there it's 10:00
a.m. over there you guys are asking
weird questions after phase 4 what
happens
mmm no idea I would hope I would like to
see an expanse of civil war but you know
we may or may not see that five things
you want to see in guardians volume and
Guardians vol - yeah and Guardians
number - Adam warlock another infinity
stone some form of Nova whether it's
Richard Ryder or Sam Alexander one of
the cosmic entities
and some mention of the Avengers yeah
Arkham City yeah no no that's not that's
not it
yeah poop on the Joker making rules for
ya there's so many questions coming in
let's see yeah yeah Arkham Knight okay
okay yeah
Rob do you think the tribunal will come
back in Secret Wars nah I don't know the
question is is the one above all even
alive in secret Wars Hickman hasn't
addressed that I have no idea if that's
the case or not
mister who's your favorite Star Wars
character in Canon or not oh definitely
Darth Revan Darth Revan was a great
character what's in store for how much
to explain face
indie comics Dragon Ball Z Marvel and DC
let's see do you better spend money on
digital comics I've had or go for the
graphic novels it depends I mean it you
know trades trades are a really good
idea and okay here's a difference guys
for those of you who are who are wanting
to get into comics and you find yourself
asking the question should you get
individual comics or should you get
trades it really depends I mean it
really depends on what you like trade
you a really good idea if you're reading
a story or you know for example like if
you wanted to read 90 hours core to the
elves Batman in game death of the family
you know the lead up to Superman truth
Superman truth itself if you wanted to
read secret Wars if you wanted to read
you know the house of M or something
like that you know those big events
trades are where you want to go because
you don't have to worry about reading
orders if what you wanted to read it's
something that's you know five issues
well then that's self-explanatory I've
simply you just get an issue you know
single issues for that in truth it just
comes down to preference you know for
example um yeah I talked to it I talked
to Barry comics um and in my you know
for my personal preference um I liked
the idea of owning individual issues you
know that are just kind of a like Star
Wars you know I bought this just because
it's a variant comic and and I like
variant comics and it looks cool like
that's why I got that you know the
variant cover um you know not varying
common area comics that's why I got the
variant cover you know because it looks
cool you know and I like that
it's really personal preference there
are some people that just like owning
the individual issues of entire events
you know they they love like you know
they'll go on by quarterly hours and by
each individual issue because they like
that they like that idea you know it's
just it's based on preference you know
but for me I like buying trades you know
I don't like having to worry about
individual especially when you're
talking about like two-year run it's
like Red Hulk there's a two-year run
under Jeph Loeb I'm not gonna buy every
single individual issue because it comes
out to be the trades are usually cheaper
than buying each individual issue and
did you like the spawn movie the spawn
of it wasn't that bad at all it was it
was pretty decent I mean it was it was
fun at the time um you know it's it's
actually surprisingly accurate in
comparison to the comic book the problem
was that like the only really good
characters were like John Leguizamo and
Michael Jai White and that was generally
rosamma was hilarious as a violator in
that movie what I want to see in
Infinity Gauntlet I want to see a bait
like I think what they're gonna do is
basically reboot the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but if there's any one thing
that I want to see in the Infinity
Gauntlet story it is Thanos wiping out
half the life in the universe by
snapping his fingers that's what I want
to see it's just like literally him just
and gone and that's it it would be a
spectacular demonstration of how
powerful the Infinity Gauntlet is not
some crazy wild major conflict or
anything like that that's why that
moment was so good because it wasn't
this great big huge crazy insane when it
was like oh my god all these things are
happening and everybody's Friday and
Thanos literally walks out to the edge
of the of the shrine snaps his fingers
and half the life in the universe is
gone and that I think is a really cool
thing you would say a lot you know and
then I think it would be pretty awesome
I blades daughter sounds yeah it sounds
a lot more interesting than it is
morning Rob I have a question will there
be more Star Wars content on your
channel probably stop moving in that
direction at some point online once we
get closer to Star Wars will move we
might move towards that direction but as
it stands right now that doesn't really
they don't really seem to be a whole lot
of interest to Star Wars on my channel
it wouldn't really seem to like it that
much and so yeah you know at the end of
the day you know I've you know I'm gonna
make videos they're gonna be successful
and so that's that's one of the things
about indie comics is kind of trying
different things seeing what I enjoy you
know in conjunction with
my fans enjoy and if I upload a video
and a majority of people just don't
watch it then obviously it's not
resonating with the majority of the fans
that I have which is fine you know
YouTube's trial and error try new things
and you know and plus the other half
this equation is you know when I was
first starting out in YouTube and we
were talking about this on periscope
yesterday you know when I was starting
out on YouTube I had no idea on how
anything worked and so I was trying to
figure things out and try new things and
I was getting burned out on making 20
minute videos I got it like making those
20 minute videos it got to the point
that by the time I stopped like I was
ready to quit YouTube like I was ready
to stop I was like I'm ready to be done
with youtube I don't ready to quit and
walk away like I got that burned out on
making 20 minute videos and and the
problem was you know I love doing
YouTube but I don't want to push myself
to the point where I literally just want
to quit and so like I just had to scale
in the videos back and then from there
people started taking off because I
wasn't sticking with the old videos and
people were leaving and then it was the
issue that I ran into was trying to
please everybody and no one at the same
time like I spent the first year of my
youtube channel trying to you know
trying to satisfy every request
everybody had people were like well you
should do 20 minute videos it's like
okay well I'll try that and they're like
no I like the shorter videos and trying
that and it was getting pulled in every
direction and I was basically shooting
myself in the foot and so I got to the
point where I was just like stop and I
just started making content that I
enjoyed and and that's where I'm at
right now so it's kind of I mean you
know I think a lot of the older fans are
just kind of like I'm out of here and
they bailed out and that's fine you know
but it is it's it's you know the key
about YouTube and here's here's the
advice that I would give any of you guys
who are wanting to get into YouTube the
key about YouTube is doing what you love
and if you love what you do then YouTube
is paradise if you hate what you do
YouTube is a nightmare and and that's
that's one of the reasons why I just
started doing everything you know
started doing stuff that I loved you
know and and and it may be that this
will all fizzle out and it may be that
this will all just go away
and it may be this will all just kind of
crumble fail and that's good and that's
it and I'll go back to working at UK and
if that's the case that's fine you know
but for me I just I like doing what I
enjoy you know and I think that's the
important thing on YouTube so um we'll
we when we see a civil war trailer in
December I was so upset about that like
they released the information about
civil war and they released some
information at d23 and they were like
the trailer officially comes out and
not December and it was like well that
sucks so let's see Rob what is the
weakest point of the inhumans from your
perspective story-wise well the problem
with that with the inhumans is nine
times out of ten they're so isolated
like they're so removed from everything
that goes on you know with with you know
with with YouTube or I'm sorry with with
the Inhumans it's it's what Marvel's
doing right now with the Inhumans as
their mission we're trying to mold them
into the x-men but the problem is the
x-men had such a long and expansive
history and so many incredible stories
that you know especially during Clair
monster and even after him you know they
were you know there were so many
incredible stories were written but the
Inhumans are basically like starting
starting all over again you know I mean
the Inhumans were featured sporadically
like here's here's what model basically
did Marvel said here's this great big
huge foundation this huge massive
skyscraper that is the x-men and here is
this you know 15-foot tall building
that's the Inhumans the Inhumans were
featured in backup story see Inhumans
were featured occasionally you know over
the course that they had limited volumes
you know a limited series you know that
lasts sometimes they lasted six issues
and they were miniseries whatever the
case may be and the Marvel said well we
can't get the right back to the x-men so
they knocked down the skyscraper and
they replaced it with this six storey
building that they're slowly starting to
build up having said that you know
Charles souls Inhumans was really really
good and if you guys haven't read it you
guys need to read it's so good it's part
of the fallout from from inhuman and
Arrakis inhumanity and the other
Terrigen mists spreading throughout the
world and it was really good you know
but they're basically trying to build
things back up and and they may be
successful you know it's just the
Inhumans don't have the same kind of
appeal as the x-men did um you know
having said that you know it's anybody
could be an inhuman now and so it's not
know the Inhumans are not mutants
they're they're a result of terrigenesis
like they have gene it's I've got a
video on it it would take me 15 minutes
to explain it but yeah it's yeah they're
not they're immunes
what if they resurrected me with the
dragonballs that would be crazy I'd love
to know how they did that looking
forward to what if green goblin gets to
infinity go I've never read that story
Illuminati in the MCU I'm kind of hoping
that happens you know I'm kind of hoping
woohoo are your top five riders Oh God
top five riders um well definitely Jeff
Jones and Scott Snyder from DC Jonathan
Hickman Brian Michael Bendis and
probably Chris Claremont or are my top
five lighters am i coming to Baltimore
comic-con yes I am
Rob heavy red Green Lantern rebirth
Sinestro Corps Lantern no well I've been
reading rebirth I'm almost through it
right now I got sidetracked with all
these videos and stuff and so you know I
definitely like to like to get back into
Green Lantern movie yeah there's like 7
a.m. in Seattle I love to get back into
Green Lantern rebirth I just haven't had
a chance yet but but I definitely want
to get into Green Lantern like we're
going through and doing like the new 52
and all that stuff and so you know since
since like since the starting point
basically like I mean here's here's what
will happen like when we go over Green
Lantern rebirth it'll literally just be
like Hal Jordan was Green Lantern for a
while they killed him off replace him
with Kyle Rayner and then they brought
him back you know and Geoff Johns Green
Lantern rebirth and then go from there
it'll be more more than that I mean it's
not gonna be just that three sentences
there'll be more to it than that you
know why they killed him off and you
know how Kyle Rayner was received and
that time between you know how Jordan
being gone and his life is the specter
and different things like that but you
know that's basically yet like if you
want to get into new 52 Green Lantern
like start with Green Lantern rebirth in
2006 and then move forward you know so
let's see Oh oops forgot to reopen the
vents on these things
Superman controlled by Lex since he is
kneeling in the treta nominal thing so I
wouldn't be surprised if Zod came back
as as doomsday though I think that's
like the rumor isn't it like Zod is
gonna be doomsday robber you coming to
New York Comic Con actually I'm not my
friends having a wedding and so I'm not
gonna be able to make it like I told
Vinnie and Sal about that already so
let's see you answer my boys question
props homie yes I did
who was your favorite flash ooh to be
honest Wally West Wally West is my
favorite flash and here's why and this
is why I don't really agree with him
bringing back Barry Allen I know I know
if there are fans of beer yeah but
here's a reason why I don't agree with
that the people who were the people who
were reading flash when DC relaunched
like when they launched new 52 or
reading Barry Allen it made no sense to
get rid of him and to replace him with
with I'm sorry they were reading Wally
West it made no sense to replace him and
and bring back Barry Allen Barry Allen
died 1985 which means that you know for
26 years you know you had people who
were reading Wally West you know why
would you take your most popular
character you know your current version
of the flash and get rid of him and
replace him with an old one that people
never read you know where that the
current generation almost never read I
mean I'm sure they were getting but the
problem is they were phasing out of
Barry Allen you know so you know even if
they were you know seven or eight or
nine or ten years old at the time that
Barry Allen was killed off in crisis on
Infinite Earths by the time it got
around you know to 2011 they were like
okay I'm on board with Wally West I mean
with Wally West we got the Speed Force
with Wally West we got all these really
cool things while he was grew as a
character grew out of the shadow of a
very Alan I mean he you know so much
work in time especially by Mark Waid was
put into Wally West you know and then
suddenly it's Wally West is gone
you know and and now so here's the
problem people have with Wally West now
and I might make a video on this you
know the problem that people have with
Wally West is he's a caricature like he
is this he's easily he's some perception
that someone had that in truth was a
very skewed perception but he's a young
african-american kid who mouths off to
Authority and no one's gonna tell him
what to do or anything
that that's preposterous you know and
fans hate that fans are like we don't
want to see stereotypes and comics we
want to see real decent representations
of people and I gotta tell you you know
as a black guy you know reading Wally
West's like you know looking like
picking up with Wally West I was pissed
I was like I'm not mad because this
isn't the Wally West that I grew up with
I'm mad because this is not a very good
depiction of you know a young black kid
and and I never really got into it but
nonetheless you know um
DC's going with their own thing far be
it for me to tell them what they can and
can't do you know I can do is just
refuse to buy into the character and
that's what I'm doing right now we're
just kind of sad to see you know because
Wally has had a great legacy a great
history yeah but um anyway you want
Wally West man yeah a lot of fans like
we want Wally West back let's see what
do you think about the other Marvel
character Wesley Snipes was talking
about that could kick plates ass um
there's a lot of characters I could
blaze ass I'm not sure let's see
he was the bomb and justice yeah have
you ever read Sonic or Mega Man I've
never read a sonic or Mega Man comic I
always thought it'd be cool to read a
Sonic or Mega Man comic but I've never
read one let's see it's do you think oh
yeah I read the chaos ward no I haven't
read the chaos were a favorite
Elseworlds story Oh Superman red Sun
that was so good it was huge but it was
so good um hopes for the flash season 2
Jay Garrick I really want to see Jay
Garrick I want to see the flash of two
worlds I want I want to see Jay Garrick
in old-school like 1940s flash the best
speedster well I mean the best speed sir
as he's depicted in DC Comics is Barry
Allen I haven't said that in my mind as
speedsters Wally West let's see should
comic stop rebooting timeline and be
like mangas and continue what mostly
here's a problem is you know like see
it's with Japan is different you know
with my my experience is isolated to
Dragon Ball Z so I'm not gonna speak for
you know any of the other mangas that
Japan has but my you know what Dragon
Ball Z was simple you know jaga Mosley
was sadhus it was eras you know you
could you can pick up
you know with with when Vegeta first
showed up you know which was the
beginning of the series to be truthful
you could pick up with Frieza you know
you could pick up with cell you can pick
up with you know all these different
characters and you could at least gain
some understanding by either reading
online or something like that with
comics it's not that easy and and here's
here's here's a problem and for those of
you guys who were who were expressing
some frustration with DC you
here's we're going to talk about that
you know here for a second and one of
the big issues with DC you that I had
was that it things were complicated and
things didn't make a whole lot of sense
you know for fans getting into DC Comics
while it seems as though they it's while
it seems as though they wouldn't care
about continuity
I'd say that's not the case you know if
fans want to know where things fit in
you know if a fan walked into a coming
bookstore and they say I want to read
Batman where do I start and the person
says well Reeve you know
quarter the aisles not of the owls and
game death of the family so on and they
read that and they say okay cool now I
want to read current Batman where do I
start and they say well you can go with
the Justice League where he's sitting on
the Morbius chair and he's God or you
can read the one where he's not Batman
in his own son in his own comic book
series and fans are like what I was like
why is the Batman in Justice League but
he's not bad man in his own series and
that confuses the heck out of fans and
confuses or at least new people it
confuses them so bad because they're
like well I mean where do they fit like
where do they fit in relation to one
another and DC's just come like well you
know and that's it man you don't really
get a clear-cut answer until some event
comes along that retcons it all it just
says well here's where everything rests
you know and you know and you have
events like features and where DC's like
hey here's what things could look like
in five years but they're not so don't
worry about it but you don't even need
to read this event and that was it you
know that's why I haven't done features
in because you don't need to read
features in that you need to read
features end for like the ending where
the anti-monitor shows up and he's like
ah
you know and that's it like I mean and
you can cover that I can cover that over
the course so I tie in you know that's
it it's not necessary you know and so it
confuses a lot of fans it throws a lot
of fans off you know it really confuses
a lot of people and any causes problems
you know but you know nonetheless I'm
not the one that makes the decisions
it's just one of those kind of weird
things Wesley Snipes wants to be in the
MCU
um what uh-ohhhhh blade I wouldn't mind
seeing Wesley Snipes is blade I mean I
think it'd be kind of cool
Tiffany versus to be honors Oh Tiffany
would destroy the be honors yeah I'm
going to Baltimore comic-con guys why
does it make sense that Batman can beat
Superman but not Superman I mean why
does it make sense a Batman could be
Superman but Superman can't be Batman
because because because it just does I
don't know it does make sense I mean
it's weird these are some of the stories
get told but okay let's be honest so
like it would be so easy I mean if you
were just like I mean how would you
create a conflict where Batman beat
Superman and I'm sorry we received man
beats Batman and not make it difficult I
mean you would literally have a comic
where Superman would just show up like
knock on Batman's door and Bruce Wayne
is like hello and Superman just like
punches his head off his shoulders and
that would be it there'd be no story to
tell so let's see what's the best Eddie
Murphy film probably Beverly Hills Cop
this is pretty amazing do I play Star
Wars Battlefront I played one and two I
haven't played three yet well I guess
three hasn't come out yet but I'm not
sure if I'm gonna play it or not
let's see updated top five artists Jim
Lee Alex Ross Greg Capullo Swain and
change how his parents died and that be
simple enough but you know it's still a
good show
let's do you think JK Simmons should
revise his role as JJ Jameson yes of
course he should JK Simmons was an
amazing jenna jameson I see Robin your
opinion which sounds like a better story
Batman kills the Marvel Universe or
Deadpool kills Oh Batman kills Batman
kills the Marvel Universe or Deadpool
kills of DC Universe Oh I'd read them
both could you imagine that Deadpool
kills the DC Universe that would blow
off do that comic would sell so many
issues and then Batman kills the Marvel
Universe would be on May
thing like like it'd be fun to do like a
hypothetical video about that you know
like Deadpool kills the DC Universe
would be fun like EBI it'd be pretty
pretty fun um I'm not sure I'd want to
do a video like that cuz a problem that
I would have is I think that that people
would feel Dukes like if I made a video
called Deadpool kills the DC Universe
people would would show a thing I'm like
oh my god what a great story like I
can't wait to watch this penny when it's
like hey guys
imagine the Deadpool killed the DC
Universe and they were just like man you
know and they'd be kind of irritated but
having said that you know maybe I'm my
title you know how could Deadpool kill
the DC Universe I think it'd be kind of
cool DC fans will be pissed man I guess
we could offset it you know how could
Batman kill the Marlee I might do that
you know how could Batman kill the
Marvel Universe you know that'd be kind
of a cool story to tell the problem is
making it visually interesting you know
and you know that'd be kind of tough to
do but I think I might do that that's a
good idea
let's see Rob how the Silver Surfer is
still alive after your Silver Surfer
right oh so we're sort of work room was
not canon that was I thought I'd mention
that yeah I mentioned that in and in the
video that it wasn't it's not part of
continuity that's an isolated story
that's completely separate in an
alternate universe so yeah let's see
what kind of guitar is that that is a
Gibson guitar what is your favorite
childhood game you do look like God with
muscles what's my favorite childhood
game Monopoly monopoly was amazing
what's your favorite brand of toilet
paper
I've actually got Charmin Charmin ultra
because you know gotta keep it soft
nobody wants to light with sandpaper
I tried cotton L one it's like cotton L
socks it's the terrible toilet paper Rob
kills the MCU like how would I kill the
moral universe um hi ba let's see
accurate explained that'd be an
interesting one Secret Wars issue 9
please yeah I'm not sure how I feel
about them doing another issue of Secret
Wars I'm kind of on the fence about that
The Secret Wars is cool you know but I
just don't know how I feel about them
doing continuing the series on it's just
dragging on and on and on and it kind of
sucks what's really interesting here is
it actually gonna be relaunch they're
gonna be launching the new Marvel
Universe after secret Wars I'm sorry
before Secret Wars is over so it's gonna
be like Secret Wars is going on and then
like they're gonna be there's gonna be
that's weird
I don't understand why Marvel's doing
that do I have a PS Vita no I don't why
are DC titles no longer related to each
other um it's not a server they're not
related to each other it's just they're
taking place different events taking
place at different times and Marvel's or
DC it's just not telling us when those
times are I don't understand what
they're doing right now I mean I just
know that the stories are kind of
interesting and it's it's different the
easiest way to explain you just don't
worry about continuity don't think of it
in terms of what are the stories relate
to one another just think of it in terms
of is the story interesting and read it
accordingly so the joke's on me I guess
what do you think about the about static
shock what do you think of static shock
at DC Universe they're an interesting
character I don't really know much about
him to be honest uh Uncle Ben for
president I would vote for Aquaman if he
were running for president why are you
called Uncle Bobby because I am amazing
that's why Rob can you do the complete
death of Superman and the rise of all
the clones it's a long story
I may do that at some point I mean the
death what I may do is just like fold
the death of Superman into my discussion
on the on the definitive the defenders
of Superman which is coming along I'm
just I'm adding to the script whenever I
have time like let's see year 1 or 0
year
hmm zero year wasn't bad zero year was
cool because you got to see Bruce Wayne
growing up you got to see him stepping
in and becoming Batman
however nobody beats Frank Miller run on
Batman
do I see Superman I don't mean Superman
Batman it shows that man growing up and
becoming you know Batman um nobody beats
Frank Miller on Batman so I mean there
you're a zero year was a really really
good foundation to explain how it was
that Bruce Wayne became Batman the early
things he went through all that kind of
good stuff
I don't know that's a difficult one but
I'd say you're one most likely I
probably have to go if I had to pick one
I'd say you're one was probably written
better
what are you what's your opinion on the
Ultimate Universe it was good at first
and then it just kind of stopped being
interesting after a while and I lost
interest in it you know and so I ended
up Rob why you know stream ever I'm
streaming right now so I ended up you
know really only focusing on on Miles
Morales and after that you know walked
away the bait boxes yeah looks like my
rooms on fire no I don't have any pets I
had a cat but he ran away a long time
ago that sucks I was crushed
oh my battery's low uh let's see I meant
why does it make sense that Batman can
be Superman but not oh why not Goku okay
Superman
okay anomaly I mean okay here's the
thing guys like like don't necessarily
take screwattack's
thing is an absolute I mean it's always
your own opinion you can I mean user
video is like a reference because they
have a lot of really good information in
their video you know but but no one
else's opinion should ever be taken as
fact I mean I always come to your own
conclusions I mean I'm sure they're
talking about two guys and two separate
universes that will never meet you know
it's impossible to determine who's gonna
beat who having said that I think it's
pretty clear they Goku would be Superman
so you know I'm just saying I don't know
there's really any debate there
um Baby Genius let's see what do you
think about Howard Howard the Duck Rob
how will the duck was interesting but he
was weird at the same time he had a big
cult following there were elements of
him that were kind of strange I really
couldn't get into him that much but you
know he did have fans he had he had
hardcore Rob knees a cable show I don't
know about that but I think it'd be kind
of cool to have a cable show oh god what
is this song I am listening
I'm sorry guys give me give me once I'm
listening to this this hip-hop mix right
now and it's the song is freaking
amazing
hey guys when you get a chance to look
up look up si NH and it's called early
spring yeah it's inh in the songs called
early spring it's good I guess is a
really good song I really enjoy it it's
got a really cool beat and my contact to
contact the guy that made the song and
just be like hey man like can do I have
can I have your permission to use this
in one my video let's see do you think
Cavs team is stronger is it fair now I
think there's teams are split pretty
evenly why weren't the x-men and
Infinity Gauntlet Cyclops was but
everybody else is assumed if something
been killed off all infinity gone did is
it took their most popular characters
and folded the man that's part of the
conflict
let's see Uncle Ben versus Alfred Oh
like Alfred any worse like it Alfred
Pennyworth that needs to happen we need
to see a battle video of like Uncle Ben
versus Alfred Pennyworth and like I'd
like to see like two old men duking it
out in the boxing ring that'd be amazing
I might do a video on that you know
Uncle Ben vs. Alfred Pennyworth you know
um yeah I think we might I think I might
do a video on that you know who would
win it wouldn't be too long between five
or six minutes because there's not a
whole lot there but you know it'd be fun
you know Alfred Pennyworth versus Uncle
Ben I think it'd be kind of funny so um
let's see
have you watched Dragon Ball super yes
I've watched talking about super I'm a
big fan of it Rob the Avengers are
obviously from characters already
established with Marvel ever contemplate
introducing a new superhero in the
movies to jewel I don't know that's a
good question though
I mean I'd be kind of down with that are
you scared of Tiffany yes and have you
met hip knee in real life you would be
to like like Tiffany's cool but Tiffany
is like a no-nonsense person and then I
mean I'm not like like scared like like
I'm timid and like I don't say anything
to and like I run and hide but I don't
think I've ever seen her angry although
I think I've seen her irritated and I'd
hate to see your angry let's see uh
Uncle Ben for the window not by a long
spider-verse why did it suck because to
me it was boring what would you like to
see happen and the Gotham series I'd
like to see it get good I stopped
watching a while ago I lost interest in
Gotham a while ago let's see uh yeah
that early Springs yeah that early
spring song is good man isn't he is it
like a good song um favorite song to
play on the guitar I don't know I mean
I'm not very good at playing it so
whatever I kind of make up I'll top my
head let's see did I read ultimate
spider-man between 2000 2009 no I didn't
read any other Peter Parker ultimate
spider-man let's see how will anyone
beat ant-man in CW Oh a Civil War no one
can see him I don't know that's good
question so nice talk we'll figure out a
way to spot him let's see hope you see
this I just wanted to know when did I
earn man makes such a jump in tech and
power and then why look how much
especially and oh he's always like it
was a gradual thing he always just
became like as the comics increases
technology increase in the world world
they were able to introduce more stuff
they'd always just kind of expanded have
I played Kingdom Hearts yes I played
Kingdom Hearts I should do a video on
valiance divinity funnily enough like I
probably gonna start doing some videos
on
relatively soon it's one of the indie
comics that want to start branching into
how long has this been going on for
about a little a little under an hour
probably gonna end it here in the next
few minutes or so but who's your
favorite member of the Justice League
and the x-men Oh
favorite member the Justice League is
probably Batman but just because he's my
general me he's my my favorite guy
because at the end of the day despite
the fact how smart he is all the stuff
he could do he's just a man and you
could kill Batman by sniping him with a
rifle from I don't know half a mile away
well you could just kill Batman that way
like this that's it like that's all you
would need to do to kill Batman is shoot
him from half a mile away I'm surprised
no one's done that that would be like
the shortest the shortest story ever
like a one-page issue like the death of
Batman and it's just like some guy on a
rooftop snapping him from a mile away
and Batman dies and that's it
like a one page issue but that's what I
like about that man is he's really so
vulnerable despite what it is he's
capable of having said that in terms of
of the Avengers I think you said my
favorite character is part of the
Avengers is probably Iron Man this cuz
he's got sort of screwed up history he's
made so many mistakes and screwed stuff
up but he's still solid and I really dig
that
let's see old man Logan after Secret
Wars yeah that'll keep going
definitely Captain America vs Batman
Batman would win let's see now if DC and
Marvel are both in multiverses and the
multiverse is generated based on quantum
physics then they both must share the
same unless I'm a quantum mechanics and
they both share the same universe oh man
they sure they imagine I share the same
multiverse but I don't know it's weird
like they had a DC multiverse or a DC
universe within Secret Wars it was
called earth to 4 million 290 and 1 I
think you like Margot as Harley yeah
she's not bad it's weird I think she's
mean depicted weird I think a lot of
like hardcore Harley Quinn fans are a
little upset at how she's being depicted
but I don't
see anything wrong with it I think she's
fine what's the the death of death all
right guys I'm gonna go ahead and bring
this livestream to an end I'd love to
stay on here but I need to finish this
script on on Batman and yeah so I guess
I guess I'll catch you guys later peace